Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper does not contain the usual fireworks
that you're used to in Two Minute Papers,
but I feel that this is a very important story
that needs to be told to everyone.
In computer science, we encounter many interesting
problems, like finding the shortest path between
two given streets in a city, or measuring
the stability of a bridge.
Up until a few years ago, these were almost
exclusively solved by traditional, handcrafted
techniques.
This means a class of techniques that were
designed by hand by scientists and are often
specific to the problem we have at hand.
Different problem, different algorithm.
And, fast forward to a few years ago, we witnessed
an amazing resurgence of neural networks and
learning algorithms.
Many problems that were previously
thought to be unsolvable, crumbled quickly
one after another.
Now it is clear that the age of AI is coming,
and clearly, there are possible applications
of it that we need to be very cautious with.
Since we design these traditional techniques
by hand, the failure cases are often known
because these algorithms are simple enough
that we can look under the hood and make reasonable
assumptions.
This is not the case with deep neural networks.
We know that in some cases, neural networks
are unreliable.
But it is remarkably hard to identify these
failure cases.
For instance, earlier, we talked about this
technique by the name pix2pix where we could
make a crude drawing of a cat and it would
translate it to a real image.
It worked spectacularly in many cases, but
twitter was also full of examples with really
amusing failure cases.
Beyond the unreliability, we have a much bigger
problem.
And that problem is adversarial examples.
In an earlier episode, we discussed an adversarial
algorithm, where in an amusing example, they
added a tiny bit of barely perceptible noise
to this image, to make the deep neural network
misidentify a bus for an ostrich.
We can even train a new neural network that
is specifically tailored to break the one
we have, opening up the possibility of targeted
attacks against it.
To alleviate this problem, it is always a
good idea to make sure that these neural networks
are also trained on adversarial inputs as
well.
But how do we know how many possible other
adversarial examples exist that we haven't
found yet?
The paper discusses a way of verifying important
properties of neural networks.
For instance, it can measure the adversarial
robustness of such a network, and this is
super useful, because it gives us information
whether there are possible forged inputs that
could break our learning systems.
The paper also contains a nice little experiment
with airborne collision avoidance systems.
The goal here is avoiding midair collisions
between commercial aircrafts while minimizing
the number of alerts.
As a small-scale thought experiment, we can
train a neural network to replace an existing
system, but in this case, such a neural network
would have to be verified.
And it is now finally a possibility.
Now, make no mistake, this does not mean that
there are any sort of aircraft safety systems
deployed in the industry that are relying
on neural networks.
No no no, absolutely not.
This is a small-scale "what if" kind of experiment
that may prove to be a first step towards
something really exciting.
This is one of those incredible papers that,
even without the usual visual fireworks, makes
me feel that I am a part of the future.
This is a step towards a future where we can
prove that a learning algorithm is guaranteed
to work in mission critical systems.
I would also like to note that even if this
episode is not meant to go viral on the internet,
it is still an important story to be told.
Normally, creating videos like this would
be a financial suicide, but we're not hurt
by this at all because we get stable support
from you on Patreon.
And that's what it is all about - worrying
less about views and spending more time talking
about what's really important.
Absolutely amazing.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!